[Music]
in tonight's whatever happened to
segment the treatment of LGBT
individuals that issue is part of the
changing cultural landscape in the u.s.
of course but is it going backward
excuse me under a conservative
administration of correspondent Doug
mackelway looks at that question tonight
I'm a follower of Jesus Christ and I
believe that the Bible clearly teaches
that marriage is between a man and a
woman that in a nutshell is why Jack
Phillips refused to bake a wedding cake
for a gay couple Charlie Craig and David
Mullins they sued Phillips appealed in
the case masterpiece cake shop versus
the Colorado Civil Rights Commission is
expected to be decided by the Supreme
Court any day at stake is whether
anti-discrimination laws can force a
business to express a speech with which
it disagrees shop owners can absolutely
decide what they serve they can make
determinations on whether or not they
make wedding cakes at all or what kinds
of designs that they place onto a
product but when a business is open they
really should be open to all
the decision will occur as US cultural
standards over sexuality and gender are
rapidly evolving North Carolina often
considered Bible Belt country found that
out the hard way two years ago when it
passed a bill restricting transgender
people's bathroom access the backlash
was severe the NCAA and the NBA pulled
games from the state that and the
threatened loss of other businesses
forced state lawmakers to roll back the
restrictions the Trump administration
has filed an amicus brief in support of
the masterpiece cake shop but it too is
moderating its position in this broader
culture war the planned ban on
transgendered in the military has been
narrowed they may serve in their
biological sex if there's been no
history of gender dysphoria the image of
socially conservative Vice President
Mike Pence swearing in the first openly
gay ambassador to Germany Richard
Grinnell with his husband holding the
Bible spoke volumes about how much
standards have changed to comply with
Colorado Civil Rights Commission's Jack
Phillips no longer bakes any wedding
cakes that cost us 40 percent of our
income at the time the emotional toll on
my family and just my life in general
has been pretty dramatic death threats
hateful emails hateful phone calls
protests a lot of things that just for
trying to live according to my faith
shouldn't happen the High Court decision
on masterpiece cake shop may again hinge
on the swing vote of Justice Anthony
Kennedy who in 2015 wrote the 5 to 4
majority opinion which legalized gay
marriage